for those of you who have seen my acne
story which I shed five years ago well
guess what the past three years has been
a terrible acne journey for me in fact
it was worse than what I experienced
seven years ago so this video is in
partnership with I earth I want to share
with you how natural supplements and
food helped with my acne if you have not
heard of IR it is a global leader in
bringing the best overall value in
natural products to their customers all
over the world they guaranteed that you
will receive the best overall value in
over 30,000 brand-name natural products
so I'm going to share my own personal
experience these are a few of my acne
pictures which to be honest I'm really
nervous right now because I've never
shared these pictures with anybody
before so that picture was taken three
years ago as you can see I knew that at
that point I'm going to go through
another phase of really terrible acne
and that was one of the lowest point in
my life I have to be honest I did go to
the beauty treatment center and went
through really painful and rough
extraction it did help a little bit for
a little while but then it got worse
again and at that time I knew that I
didn't want to go down the road of
taking medicine drugs again because I've
done that before and once I stopped I
know that my acne is gonna come back if
you can look at my skin right now this
is me without any makeup on except a
little bit of eye makeup so if you do
notice I do still experience breakout
and also post acne scarring and this
picture right here this picture was
actually taken right after a workout
session I mean to be honest at that
point I actually lost all confidence I
mean I do receive a lot of comments from
you guys asking me to share about my
skin routine my hair routine but deep
down that was what I was going through
and
I mean like I know people say that your
skin doesn't define you but when you
have to constantly be in front of the
camera you have to constantly be filming
or attend events you know I just I could
not go out with a face like that I know
that makeup is bad for your skin
but at the same time if I don't put on
makeup I just don't have the confidence
to go out so I I went through that
really bad phase I would say for two
years from early 2016 to early 2018 it
was constant up and down constant up and
down if you look at my lifestyle I do
believe that I eat well and I do lead an
active lifestyle I work out at least
four times a week so at that point I
knew that it has nothing to do with the
kind of the the types of food I'm eating
all my lifestyle but it was more of
hormonal acne in my case I remember even
telling my videographers to never take
any close-up shots of me stay as far as
you can do not capture my skin and then
you know you ask yourself why me why do
I have to go through this again yes my
skin has improved tremendously for the
past one year but if you ask me do will
I ever go through this again the truth
is I don't know but for the past two
years I've experimented with different
treatments as well as different products
and I want to share with you these five
natural supplements which have helped
with my acne I got all my products from
I up because they offer a triple
guarantee to ensure that their customers
of 100% satisfied as a california-based
superstore they guarantee that all their
products are authentic brands sold in
the US market and is committed to
provide a quality assurance for all
their products plus they're shipped
directly from climate control to
warehouses so I know exactly what I'm
putting into my body
so this first product is Nature's Way
notified dual-action
digestive complete probiotics and
enzymes ever since I was young I knew
that I have poor digestion
I do suffer from IBS bloating a gas and
even constipation even the smallest
trigger whether it's from my food or
even stress will affect my digestion so
I knew that no matter how well I ate my
body wasn't fully absorbing the
nutrients so since taking this product
it has helped to balance my gut and
allowing my body to better absorb the
nutrients hence I have seen improvement
on my skin and my skin is less irritated
so other high probiotic foods include
temper kombucha kimchi sauerkraut ACV
yogurt and even cheese so these are
really good probiotic foods which you
can add more into your diet
the next supplement is Nature's Way
alive hair skin and nails multivitamin
some of the vitamins and minerals which
can help with your skin health include
vitamin A C D E K zinc magnesium and
selenium and this supplement contains
all the vitamins and minerals and more
remember acne equals inflammation
vitamin A has antioxidant properties
which can help to reduce inflammation in
my case it has helped to reduce the
redness of my skin some of the fruits
and vegetables which are high in vitamin
A includes squashes bell pepper oranges
tomatoes carrots basically just think of
red and orange fruits or vegetables zinc
also acts as a powerful
anti-inflammatory and antioxidant hence
helping me achieve clearer skin
magnesium on the other hand helps with
stress related acne I knew that at that
period in my life I was going through a
lot of stress because at that point I
just started my own company so in a way
it's not just my hormone but also my
stress level so taking this supplement
in fact has helped me to balance my
hormone levels when it comes to food
which are high in zinc and magnesium you
can go for shellfish nuts and seeds
especially pumpkin and sesame seeds
soybeans such as edamame my favorite
dark leafy greens especially spinach as
well as avocado the next supplement is
something we all should consume whether
or not you suffer from acne fish oil
mainly for its omega-3 fatty acids
omega-3 is especially useful if you do
suffer from hormonal acne which is my
case it has to regulate acne causing
hormones such as testosterone which
causes the overproduction of sebum so
foods high in omega-3 fatty acids which
I like to consume include cold water
fatty fish such as mackerel salmon tuna
herring and sardines as well as nuts and
seeds such as flax seeds chia seeds and
walnuts so we all know the benefits of
omega-3 but we often overlook the
benefits of omega-6 so my next product
is Nature's Way evening primrose too
much of amiga 6 is bad for you so it is
about finding the balance between having
enough omega-3 as well as omega-6 in
your diet the most significant
attributes of evening primrose is
helping with hormonal imbalance this can
also help yourself to rebuild and
rejuvenate itself which can help with
post acne scarring so this is a high in
omega-6 fatty acids heme flax grape
pumpkin sunflower as well as acai and
the final product has to be my favorite
I apply this on a daily basis Nature's
Way hide replenish which is a hydration
facial therapy so my skin type is dry
but at the same time I can't apply those
heavy cream because it will cause my
paws to clog up so I really like this
serum because it leaves my skin feeling
light and hydrated without feeling
greasy it is really simple all you have
to do is press about 2 pumps onto your
skin and just rub it and dab it onto
your skin I like to use it immediately
after shower and even when I'm out and
about and whenever I feel my skin is dry
that's when I will use this as well this
product also contains a vitamin C and
vitamin C helps with the production of
collagen and this can help with your
skin especially
after a major acne breakout I love this
and I do use this on a daily basis it
has helped to brighten my complexion and
reduce post acne scarring and you know
what you can even use this on top of
your makeup whenever you feel that your
skin is dry or tight you can get all of
my favorite products from IR they
guarantee delivery of your order and
provide free or discounted shipping to
over 150 countries and if you do live
outside of the US do check out a UPS
shipping methods to your country in the
link below and be sure to check out my
description box for links to all the
products mentioned in this video so this
is my own personal journey of battling
against acne if you're going through it
right now
I know how it feels and it can affect
your confidence level but the truth is
that it will not cure overnight it will
not cure you know in a week's time it
might take years in my case but it's
very important to continue to feed your
body with good food and supplements and
stay active on a regular basis okay look
after your body as well as your mental
and emotional health so if you're going
through acne right now share your story
with me in the comments below be sure to
give this video a thumbs up do share
this video with someone who might be
suffering from acne and I hope that you
will find this video useful and don't
forget to subscribe to my youtube
channel for a lot more nutritional tips
healthy recipes as well as workout
videos all the best and share your acne
story with me